joining us online is james o'keefe he's
the founder of project veritas and
project veritas action he founded those
after he'd pulled off some of the most
consequential undercover journalism
who's in a generation of course he's
become target number one for the
so-called journalismers all of the
journalists who spend their days jim
acosta all over themselves james joins
at the show now he's brand new book
american muckraker rethinking journalism
for the 21st century james thanks so
much for joining the show
ben great to be with you okay so let's
talk about the way that the journalistic
establishment treats the kind of stuff
that you do it really is kind of amazing
you've broken an enormous number of
stories over the past
few years i mean going back basically a
decade at this point i remember when you
first walked into andrew breitbart's
office with tape from acorn i remember
being there when that happened it's been
a long time since you started off here
and you've broken an enormous number of
consequential stories that have
generated legislation and they've
generated national response and yet the
media treat you as a pariah they suggest
that you are not in fact engaged in
journalism why the gap
well ben i think historically there's
always been a tension between access and
autonomy in the media on one hand you
don't want to bite the hand that feeds
you your sources
in the government in inside these
organizations so project veritas we use
undercover techniques use whistleblowers
it's a different way of being
independent well you're not extolling
the virtue of these government officials
you're challenging them without
misrepresenting them the way that the
spoken word can so this book american
mark waker is kind of a handbook about
how to do journalism in clown world in a
world where for example the fbi the
pharmaceutical companies and the new
york times are working in concert with
one another to suppress information and
to target journalists i think people
need a handbook for how to speak the
truth in such a world
you know james one of the things that
you see very often is that there is a
complete double standard in terms of the
exact modes that you you use so you use
particular methods use a lot of
undercover journalism uh secret cameras
and the like when the left does that and
the target is somebody of the right then
it is wildly cheered i remember in 2012
one of the crucial parts of the campaign
was when a mother jones reporter
secretly taped mitt romney talking about
47 of the american population not voting
for him because a lot of people don't
pay income tax in the country and this
was considered a wildly excellent coup
by by mother jones if you however catch
a public official admitting to
corruption on tape this means that
you're the bad guy
yeah there's a whole chapter in this
book then about deception they say well
you deceive people you use undercover
techniques well they say it's about the
methods but in actuality and you know
this ban it's about the findings they
worry far less about ethics than whose
ox
is being gored is really what they care
about and that for example you have the
planned parenthood videos the the body
part fetal bit the videos david delide
and the undercover reporter recorded
those let's say he had used hidden
cameras into animal cruelty nobody would
be debating the ethics of whether you
could record someone and furthermore ben
as a harvard law graduate you know uh
brandeis wrote an article called the uh
the right to privacy and really you know
if you're with the person you're talking
to if you're if you're participating in
the conversation that you're having
project veritas myself would argue that
uh you have a constitutional right to
record that conversation as long as the
person knows that they're with you and
we talk a lot about privacy and consent
and this sort of revolution of
whistleblowers and hidden cameras across
the country which we think we think that
if people can see the reality if they
can see the raw information for
themselves we trust the people to draw
their own conclusions and we don't want
to just give them the conclusions the
way that the press does on on tv network
news there's anything james o'keefe his
new book is american muckraker
rethinking journalism for the 21st
century so james what is your
verification protocol so obviously you
have major newspapers and magazines and
they have fact checkers on staff who
sometimes make mistakes and and gets
pretty ugly um but they at least have a
supposed process that they run through
where they're supposed to go through
everything that they print and make sure
that what they print is not libelous or
slanderous what is the the sort of
verification protocol you go through
when you decide to run a video
well there's a whole chapter in this
book i call image and in this chapter of
american muckraker i talk about i talk
about that precise thing you know we
believe in this so idea of participation
observation journalism it's pretty
straightforward it enables a reporter to
see and hear things with his own eyes
and ears and that is a virtue and given
that accuracy is journalism's most
fundamental objective it's an extremely
important virtue and and one that should
not be you know sacrificed to a rigid
rule against deception so the answer
question is oftentimes you don't i don't
ask you to trust me i give you the
information you could see it for
yourselves last week it was documents
inside the defense department or it's a
recording of someone and you might say
well how do we know the people who are
saying the thing in the recording uh are
telling the truth
and and we do
talk to as many sources as we need to
talk to to confirm that the thing is
happening but oftentimes it's
aesthetically true the people did make
those statements they're caught on tape
and when we look at the washington post
and someone like jacob bagaj the
washington post who says well we're
credible journalists well they're asking
you to trust them by virtue of their own
decree that they are indeed credible so
it's a self-anointed racket we don't ask
you to trust me because i'm credible we
ask you to trust the evidence of your
eyes and ears and as we know from george
orwell's 1984 that the party asks you to
reject the evidence of your eyes and
ears and that's really the problem we
have so it's i think it's this idea of
first
person participant observation
journalism where the viewer can see the
evidence for themselves
alrighty folks more with james o'keefe
in just one moment first let me just
tell you about the best knives on the
market i'm talking about kamakoto knives
they're so good i didn't even bring them
back for the ad they're just that good i
literally use them every single day
kamakoto makes great japanese steel
kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from japan that have been
honed and perfected by generations of
knife smiths they only use steel sourced
from mills in japan their expert
bladesmiths forge and shape raw steel
into hardy blades polishing and
sharpening them to an excruciatingly
fine edge each knife comes in a
beautiful heavy duty ash wood box that
makes sure that the knife is stored
safely it also makes kamikoto a
fantastic gift kamakoto is so confident
about their knives that each knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee because of
their single beveled edge kamikoto
knives can achieve an unbelievably sharp
edge you just can't get with other
knives they cut through your rib eye
like butter kamakoto is currently having
a massive extended new year sale on top
of that sale you can get an additional
50 bucks off any purchase you make with
discount code ben shapiro so click the
link below or go to kamakoto.com
ben shapiro use promo code ben shapiro
save an extra 50 bucks today
you know james one of the things that i
think has happened over the course of
journalistic history is there's a shift
from journalism as a process to
journalists as a profession you see this
in science also right when you see
anthony fauci saying that he is the
science as opposed to the scientific
process being the science the the
process of journalism which really was
sort of initiated by walter lippman in
the early 20th century the idea was that
you go through particular protocols and
that if you do these particular things
at the end of the day what you will come
up with is a story that is verifiable
and journalistic and instead what
happened is that a professional cadre of
journalists started going to journalism
school and because they had a credential
the idea was that somehow they were now
more reliable and verifiable and you see
the effects of this so just in the last
36 hours you had nina totenberg from npr
report a story about the supreme court
she suggested that chief justice john
roberts told neil gorsuch and the other
members of the court they had to mask up
because sonia sotomayor is a diabetic
and that he had refused to mask up
because he doesn't care essentially if
sonya says to me or gets coveted and
dies and the entire supreme court denies
this roberts denies it so to me or
denies this gorsuch like they all deny
it and npr is standing by because the
idea is that nina totenberg is a good
reporter she's a good journalist and
because she's a journalist we don't have
to actually determine whether this was
an act of journalism she has the title
and that's all that matters meanwhile
you james you're not a journalist so you
should not be given the same protections
as other journalists even if you are
committing acts of journalism
yeah i'm glad you brought up you know
lipman and some of these deans of
journalism who are these journalism gods
that dictate to us these things there's
this whole chapter called propaganda in
this book american muckraker and in the
early 20th century there were a lot of
these journalism deans
edward brenes wrote a book called
propaganda and uh they talked about this
idea of necessary illusions and
stereotypes that we can't give people
the raw information because people are
too stupid the the the herd of people
out there cannot
process this information and really it's
of conflict of visions ben i think a lot
of these people they talk about
disinformation what this information
really is is it's accurate facts that
lead to conclusions they don't want you
to have
so we saw that yesterday with the brian
stelter thing the nina totenberg thing
the npr thing we can shatter those
illusions but it's going to take a
little bit of pain and sacrifice and
courage because citizens out there brave
whistleblowers we've worked with so many
whistleblowers been inside government
including last week the defense
department they got nowhere else to go
they certainly can't go to nina
totenberg at npr with their revelations
so there needs to be some place for them
to go to bring the information out to
shatter the illusions and the first
chapter of my book american market is
called suffering and it kind of reads
like a dostoevsky novel it takes you
through this journey of pain and
sacrifice because yeah you do face
reputational hazards but i think we have
a choice to make as americans do we
really want to put our mortgage and our
pension above our own conscience people
are feeling that crisis of conscience
and i've written a book that hopefully
appeals to the average man because i
think it's going to take normal everyday
honest hard-working americans to shine a
light on what's going on inside their
institutions james o'keefe his book is
american muckraker rethinking journalism
for the 21st century so james one of the
obstacles that you face obviously is
social media which is constantly
constructing rules that seem almost
designed to hamper you specifically they
come up with these new rules with regard
to for example distribution of the
images of others which would shut down i
think half of journalism online and they
say this is all about as you say privacy
or this is all about guarding the image
of the person who is on tape but but
does violate sort of the basic kind of
common law belief that that you do not
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
in in public or that you don't have a
reasonable expectation of privacy if
you're in a public conversation with 10
other people or something all right what
do you make of social media is one it
really seems like a one-sided attempt to
quash your material in particular
yeah i mean this whole idea that you
twitter had a policy recently you're not
allowed to record people without them
knowing without their permission this is
blatantly unconstitutional particularly
in one party consent states and and you
think about it just use it using common
sense it doesn't it doesn't make any
sense the hidden camera is an extension
of a pencil and paper and certainly a
society would not consider reasonable an
expectation privacy that would render a
less accurate versions of the events in
question
you know something that we should be
disseminating so we would argue that
that policy is trying to
trying to control
the dissemination of images and reality
and you know whether it's police
officers uh and a riot whether it's uh
what we do it's an unconstitutional
argument ben
you're an attorney we've been to court
so many times and we keep winning these
lawsuits because these these arguments
break down in court they break down as
as basic logic recording someone doesn't
violate their privacy if you're with the
person it might violate their sense of
dignity to control the dissemination of
their own
image but it's not a violation of their
privacy it's not a type of entrapment
it's not even deceiving them it's it's
actually more it does them more justice
to show a recording of a conversation
than it does to characterize it and i
went back and read up some sinclair's
the jungle and i found some of his
writing he dramatized and interpreted it
so when you can see it with your own
eyes and ears again it goes back to this
idea of reality and things are not as
they seem and rarely as they should be
to quote the late mike wallace so these
policies are going to break down and yes
we're banned on twitter ben where
project veritas is banned i'm banned but
the story we did about the pentagon
papers last week specifically the darpa
documents that showed anthony fauci was
was potentially lying under oath those
documents were
the number one story trending story on
twitter even though i was banned so we
believe that content is king if this
story is strong enough it will diffuse
its way into all the mediums and media
and i think people need to focus on
getting that those strong content
stories rather than just complaining
about the censorship james o'keefe's new
book is american muckraker rethinking
journalism for the 21st century so final
question for you james i mean one of the
questions that i get most often because
i'm lucky i have a really fun job i get
to commentate on politics all day and
give my opinions on it but one of the
questions i get asked most often is how
do you get into the industry so there
are a lot of people who look at the
stuff that you do and the difference
they're making they say how do i get
into doing that so what's your advice
for a young person who's looking to
break stories what's your advice for
somebody who wants to get into the
political journalism industry
well i would say you learn more on the
job in three months than you do in j
school i mean i i started a paper i know
ben you were involved in
at ucla i started a campus paper at
rutgers i was 19. i just i just went out
and did it i didn't know what i was
doing i i was on campus so i was pretty
safe i went into my
public records hall this was a state
university rutgers and i got access to
all the salaries of my professors so i
think you're going to learn by doing and
to follow up with that then i think we
we have a crisis of conscience in this
country
to quote sultanates and are we going to
survive at any price are we going to let
society collapse because of how divided
we are and i think we can't live in fear
and i can't philosophize your audience
to become courageous i can't convince
you to go out and do journalism but what
i can tell you is that people who do it
set the example for others and some of
these brave whistleblowers like melissa
inside pfizer or richard hopkins at usps
or david johnson at hasbro toys the
black 25 year old engineer from rit who
blew the whistle on critical race theory
they inspired more people to come to us
so courage is courageous we gotta act we
have to go out and expose them because
at the end of the day what i believe in
this book american muckraker i write
this the only thing that communists fear
is being exposed
well the book once again is american
muckraker the author is james o'keefe
james really appreciate the time and
good luck with the book
thank you ben
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content